die korona pandemie hat den rasanten
anstieg der podcast nutzung weiter
befeuert unterhaltungsformate interviews
krimis natürlich auch nachrichten
podcast die audioformate wachsen in
allen bereichen des podcast segments
rasant weiter und locken auch rund um
die vermarktung die ganz großen des web
apple amazon spotify wie setzt sich
dieser trend in den kommenden monaten
und jahren fort und was macht die
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung im
audiomarkt darüber wollen wir heute
reden ja herzlich willkommen liebe
hörerinnen und hörer zu einer neuen
folge unseres faz digitec podcasts heute
nicht mit alexander armbruster der ist
im wohlverdienten urlaub dafür mit
anderen sehr netten kollegen nämlich
florian budnik product manager digital
products bei der faz und dort zuständig
für audio und newsletter herzlich
willkommen liebe florian hallo gast mit
vielen dank dass ich dabei sein darf
toll dass du dir die zeit genommen hast
und ja mein name ist carsten knop ich
bin herausgeber der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung und eine der digi
tec co host bekennen uns genau weil sie
engagierte podcast hörerinnen und hörer
sind und vielleicht schon viele die tech
podcast folgen gehört haben und damit
sind sie voll im trend wenn man so sagen
darf weil dieser podcast markt boomt in
einer geradezu unglaublichen art und
weise der audio streaming anbieter
spotify und vielleicht hören sie hier
die gt grade war spotify hat im vierten
quartal also am ende des vergangenen
jahr schon mehr als 50.000
deutschsprachigen podcasts auf seiner
plattform gezählt und im jahr 2018 und
es ist fast unglaublich waren es 2000
und also wenn das keine explosion ist
dann weiß ich nicht lieber florian du
hast ja auch mal
die damit verbundenen hörerzahlen und
podcasthörer nach 14 jahren den
millionen an gehört also dieses angebot
an podcasts das trifft auch auf eine
wachsende hörerschaft ja in der tat das
ist schon relativ krass man denkt 2015
gibt zumindest bitkom-studie anwalt 7,3
millionen hörer ab 14 jahren und es 2020
bis zu 25 millionen also das ist schon
richtig richtig krass wie viele leute
mittlerweile podcasts hören
ich stelle mir immer die frage ob die
ihnen auch bewusst dass das ein podcast
oder auch sehr einfach sein das ist
nämlich so ein stück unterhaltung und
gerade in der pandemie ist es glaube ich
ein medium gewesen und man sich so ein
bisschen auch die stimmen der anderen
vielleicht einholen konnte wenn man
sonst vielleicht ein bisschen einsam
aber ja die pandemie hat er nochmal wie
bei allen informationsangeboten muss man
sagen aber eben auch dort nummern
deutlichen schub gegeben
es gibt übrigens in deutschland also und
digitec gehört leider nicht zu den fünf
top podcast in deutschland
mit ihrer hilfe kann es ja noch werden
also auf platz eins sind die kollegen
von gemischtes hug und dann kommt fest
und flauschig die sind ganz ganz vorne
fallen dir spontan noch weitere
bestseller 1 florian und vor allen
dingen hast du selber auch jenseits von
faz angeboten über die wir vielleicht
später dann auch noch reden aber jetzt
erstmal mit blick auf den gesamtmarkt
auch eigene favoriten wo du gerne mal
rein hörst ich bin mittlerweile ein
bisschen auf dem trip dass ich diese ich
habe meine standard podcast wie gefühlte
fakten und podcast oper die ich
eigentlich schon höher seite gibt und da
auch mit gewachsenen das sind so wo ich
hier zum letzten werden der kann den ich
auch drauf gekommen sind kurze serien
zum beispiel hat die atlantic die serie
gehabt zehn folgen glaube ich über die
überflutung in in amerika das gleiche
dann auch zum irakkrieg und zu
afghanistan wo man erst die hintergründe
was man noch so gar nicht wusste oder
jetzt zu kuba das ist immer so zehn
folgen um den dreh und da schmecken
mit zeitzeugen die dabei waren aber auch
einfach eine stunde lang mit
hintergrundgesprächen und so kriegt man
halt ein ganz neues bild und es ändert
dann auch doch immer wieder so ein
bisschen das bild was man auf den
historischen moment hatte und das finde
ich immer sehr spannend und dadurch dass
es nur so zehn folgen sind hat man noch
nicht so den druck weil zeit ist ja doch
immer ein faktor
und wenn ich mich jetzt wieder man sich
kommissar für eine folge der serie die
jede woche eine stunde dauert das muss
ja auch erstmal ins zeitbudget deswegen
gucke ich dass ich beim neuen podcast
immer so ein bisschen show sind die
vielleicht auch nur begrenzt weil der
kanal nicht schöne schöne geschichte
erzählen können
das ist halt sein sowas abgeschlossen
ist also man muss nicht unbedingt dann
sich com bieten wie wenn man was ich
nicht in neun staffeln ehren einer
amerikanischen fernsehserie jetzt noch
schnell nachholen muss weil alle davon
reden und man sollte sich ab könnte ja
auch bei podcast so ein effekte seien
aber ja wurde wurde es schon sagst mit
mit der zeit die man dafür aufwendet das
geht ja in der tat für alle die sich
dazu entscheiden diesen podcast markt
einzusteigen hast du denn erkenntnisse
gibt es erkenntnisse mag wann podcast
gehört werden also man würde ja intuitiv
sagen na ja die leute hören morgens die
meisten podcast aber eventuell stimmt
das gar nicht die sind vor dem zeitpunkt
genau gibt es glaube ich gar nicht so
viele auswertungen weil das immer der
download ist damit gezählt wird aber was
spotify und so kommunizieren ist dass es
immer ganz gerne als wenn man sich nicht
hundertprozentig darauf konzentriert
wird es während der hausarbeit oder auch
im fitnessstudio oder natürlich dass wir
in der pandemie auch so ein bisschen
gemerkt haben auf dem weg zur arbeit das
ist einfach so ein video ist wo man auch
mal kurz weg düsen kann und dann immer
noch einsteigen kann und vor allem was
nicht mehr machen aber das ist sowieso
ein teil davon weil es gibt auch viele
leute die höheren den podcast sobald er
verfügbar ist und das ist auch wichtig
dass man da eine regelmäßigkeit
reinbringt mit einem schein mit einer
erscheinungsweise weil er gewöhnt sich
auch der der hörer so ein bisschen dran
das würde also bedeuten dass man gar
nicht also dass man eigentlich nur
festhalten kann es wird über den ganzen
tag
hinweg gehört und die situation ist
entscheidend in der man es hört also es
kann der weg zur arbeit sein da von der
arbeit oder zurück im fitnessstudio kann
ich ja im prinzip je nachdem wie meine
arbeits oder lernzeiten liegen als
student auch mehr oder weniger rund um
die uhr sein und wenn ich es beim bügeln
oder putzen höre geht es hier analog na
also man muss sich als podcast macher so
ein bisschen davon verabschieden dass
das jetzt was wir morgens oder abends
ist sondern sich darauf einstellen und
das ist ja vielleicht auch ein
erfolgsgeheimnis für dieses format das
die nutzer einfach selbst entscheiden
wann sie es hören punkt oben
das ist dieses on demand war ja auch mit
netflix in allem kam was ich glaube ich
in dem podcast auch ich finde es dennoch
spannend dass regelmäßigkeit der
erscheinung immer noch wichtig ist es
fasziniert mich auch schon bei youtube
videos wo die influenza auch regelmäßig
sagen 16 uhr donnerstags kommt mein
video raus und das ist bei podcast
teilweise ähnlich das ist einfach auch
eine erwartungshaltung des trostes
samstag
ich habe das schon eingeplant das ins
eckige und dann möchte ich ganz gern mal
ein podcast team gehören also dass es
geht mir dann auch selbst so wenn die
mal sommerpause machen oder winterpause
dann fehlt dann doch was weil das doch
eine lieb gewonnene tradition ist jemand
da auch mit anhört ja aber das wird man
ja bedeuten dass es vor allen dingen um
die fans geht
wenn menschen sagen das ist mein podcast
dann kann ich mir das gut vorstellen
dann bin ich zum beispiel bei digitec
freitags am start und hören wir die
neueste folge an weil ich weiß ist es
freitags immer neu aber für diese
sporadischen die mal hier mal da ran
hören das ist dann auch noch wieder eine
wichtige differenzierung gilt es nicht
andererseits wenn man natürlich auch
immer mehr echte treue fans haben und da
ist die regelmäßigkeit entscheiden
das stimmt und bei den anderen ist es
wichtig dass man auch entdeckt wird und
so dieses stichwort des karol bielecki
also dass man gute titel hat gesucht
wird aber auch mehr präsenz bekommt auf
den plattformen was ja doch immer wieder
so ein kleines problem ist ich meine du
hast gemischt das hat vorher schon
angeschoben
die sind ja auch in deutschland die
größten aber die sind auch weltweit auf
platz acht und das ist schon unglaublich
jedes mal zu
und im deutschen ist auch die drei
fragezeichen sind auch zum beispiel was
spotify immer sagt die sind auch sehr
stark gehört in deutschland und spielen
da auch in der welt groß mit und da ist
es schwierig wie kommt man an diesem
großen dran verweilt das auch gesagt mit
den 50.000 podcast dies bis oder die
50.000 podcast es gibt da wie schafft
man sind überhaupt nur dass man da
gefunden wird das finde ich ist eine
sehr spannende frage die man die in der
nächsten zeit beantwortet werden muss
weil ansonsten gibt es dann immer noch
wachsende größere aber so diese kleinen
die von unten hoch kommen das wird immer
unwahrscheinlicher
glaube ich zumindest ja ich denke auch
da dürfte was dran sein mit jedem neuen
der in den markt kommt wird schwieriger
aufmerksamkeit zu erzeugen vor allen
dingen wenn man dann keine medienmarke
oder so als als fördernde plattform aus
eigener kraft dann noch dahinter hat
also dieses grass roots wir kommen von
ganz unten aus dem heimischen wohnzimmer
da muss man schon sehr viel glück haben
künftig in diesem konzert noch mit
gehört zu werden
wer natürlich helfen kann
bei denjenigen die schon da sind dass
man sieht dass da was ist sind diese
schon erwähnten amerikanischen in der
regel sind es ja meist amerikanische
plattform die ein sehr starkes augenmerk
auf den podcast mag geworfen haben und
da gibt es ja zum beispiel bei apple
noch was relativ neues ja genau am apple
hat die im podcast subscription erst vor
kurzem gestartet und da ist die idee
dahinter dass man wie man es auch bei
den apps kann mit in app käufen sich
zusatz features freischalten kann
das ist fängt an bei einer werbefreiheit
die man hat über eine zeitliche frühere
verfügbarkeit oder auch eine längere
archiv zugang oder einfach ganz
exklusive episoden die es sonst nicht
gibt und das ist ein sehr spannendes
modell weil apple bisher immer so ein
bisschen spotify wird gerne vorgeworfen
dass sie den den wallet garten anbieten
aber es muss alles in spotify
stattfinden sonst ist es nicht relevant
und apple war immer so ein bisschen die
die großen die aber auch noch was für
das ganze ökosystem
an haben und da ist es jetzt mal
spannend zu sehen wie sich das auswirkt
wenn apple möglich sagt wir haben
exklusive inhalte bei uns auf den
plattformen die ja oft und pflegen müsst
was das mit dem podcast marktmacht ob es
dann den wechsel hin gibt zu mehr leuten
die sagen wir machen es exklusiv jetzt
auch apple podcast oder ob es gar nicht
so wirklich groß ankommt das ist gerade
sehr spannend zu sehen wie sich das
weiter entwickelt und was da was da raus
kommt und ob es überhaupt eine
zahlungsbereitschaft gibt das haben wir
im internet schon lange die diskussion
ob man dafür bezahlen texten na ja da
hat unsere branche ja auch lange
jedenfalls in deutschland davor
zurückgeschreckt geld zu verlangen das
hat sich ja wenn ich das so was der
position eines faz mitarbeiter sagen
darf zum glück in den vergangenen jahren
relativiert dass am markt es daher
deutlich reifer geworden was im
journalismus und der qualität echt nicht
schadet und genau beim podcast markt
steht diese erkenntnis noch außen sind
nutzer tatsächlich bereit
wie auch immer hohen beitrag in die hand
zu nehmen und zu sagen ja dafür zahle
ich gerne geld also dafür ist auch dass
apple angebot noch zu neu oder um da
irgendwelche erkenntnisse schon guten
rausgezogen haben zu können ja das
glaube ich auch was man bei podcast aber
stark sieht und eigentlich schon immer
sei es dieses bei ich spende was für
meinen lieblings podcast dass die besser
produzieren können da ist petri an
amerikanische plattform ganz großes ganz
großer anfang gewesen wo man sagen kann
ich mache jetzt wenn ich hundert leute
habt ihr mir jeweils 3 euro geben
im monat dann kriege ich meine 300 euro
im monat und kann dann und biete eine
extra folge an für die wenn ich die
nächsten step erreichen
600 euro dann gibt es zwei folgen oder
ich kaufe mir neues mikrofon dafür ist
sehr transparent mit dem hörer
ausgemacht worden vom produzenten wenn
ihr mich unterstützt dann kriegt ihr das
und das exklusiv aber es war immer so
ein bisschen was hat was gespendet und
man hat sich gekauft und den
paradigmenwechsel finde ich ganz
spannend bei apple podcast und da bin
ich auch mal gespannt was bei rauskommt
wie sich das entwickelt nur weil diese
spenden modell ist es ja so dass also
ich stelle mir jetzt gerade vor ich wäre
jemand der wirklich davon abhängen würde
das der podcast läuft ja dann könnte ich
aber
den spenden mein leben nicht bestreiten
vielleicht würden würde mir meine
hörerschaft an meine technik sponsoren
aber leben könnte ich davon ja noch
nicht insofern so ein nachhaltiges
geschäftsmodell auf spenden aufbauen ist
ja dann doch eher schwierig insofern
müsste man ja fast hoffen dass dieser
ansätze das zu monetarisieren
erfolgreich sind noch mehr wenn man an
freiberufliche podcaster denkt jetzt als
an mitarbeiter von von medienunternehmen
das ist richtig ich finde da auch ich
glaube da kommen dann auch ganz andere
geschichten daraus eine ganz andere
detailtiefe wenn man wirklich für den
inhalt bezahlt und nicht gespendet
dass das dann bin ich mal gespannt wie
sich der deutschland entwickelt und was
für geschichten da noch kommen werden
weil es ja auch so da kann man ja auch
dann mit einer sehr kleinen blase aber
eine regelmäßige oder kleinere
zielgruppe dann doch noch gut was
erreichen wenn die hat einfach bereit
sind regelmäßig die inhalte zu kaufen
dann wirklich auch dafür zu bezahlen und
es hat nicht zu diesen spenden charakter
genommen ist halt einfach nicht von von
der zufälligkeit so sehr abhängig und
natürlich wäre das der qualität
förderlich nun könnte man ja sagen na ja
also mein gott was brauchen die noch
geld über solche abo modelle die
verkaufen ja auch schon werbung in ihrem
podcast ist das ein interessantes
geschäft wie sie die die entwicklung auf
dem werbemarkt in dieselbe audio
eigentlich aus und wie sehen die hörer
das also man könnte ja auch sagen die
sind davon völlig abgetaucht vielleicht
aber auch nicht du weißt es besser ja
das ist ganz spannend da wird mit einer
70 prozentigen 70 prozent der hörer sie
in werbung positiv im podcast und ich
glaube das hängt damit zusammen dass
viel werbung auch wirklich von den
podcast an selbst gesprochen wird und
dass die werbung doch meistens noch sehr
sehr nah dran es am produkt und noch
nicht so in dieses ich sag's mal wie der
abverkauf rübergeflogen ist wie es jetzt
im radio ist und da sind auch die zahlen
wieder 2016 war es um die 25 millionen
digital audio wärmeentwicklung und jetzt
2021 wird gerechnet mit 78 millionen
also da ist schon sehr viel
wird obwohl man sagen muss wir sind da
amerika noch sehr weit hinten dran weil
wir dieses sponsoring in deutschland
nicht so stark an das glaube ich eine
der gründe also dieser podcast
repräsentiert von das gibt es hier nicht
so sehr dass das gibt es schon aber es
ist dann immer noch so im wachsen und
das ist nicht dass es das geld kommt
meistens immer noch aus dem vertrieb und
nicht aus dem marketing und ich glaube
in amerika ist es so ein bisschen aber
auch einfach bekannter was was audio
werbung da an geht weil der markt
einfach nochmal deutlich größer ist und
die haben glaube ich zu radio auch noch
mal so ein bisschen ein anderes
verhältnis über diese satellite radio
deswegen ist es spannend wie sich das in
deutschland entwickelt ich sehe da gute
chancen jetzt mit denen für das rennen
sicherten search und es ist im prinzip
nichts anderes als dass in dem podcast
werbung nicht mehr von hand fest
geschnitten wird sondern dynamischer
eingepflegt werden kann
und das macht natürlich für den
werbekunden einfacher zu sagen ich
möchte gerne dass und das inventar haben
aber es macht auch für den für den
podcast einfacher sich zu vermarkten
weil bisher haben wir so ein bisschen
das problem alte episoden werden
teilweise gar nicht mehr vermarktet und
das würde mit zu einem dynamischeren
system natürlich deutlich besser
funktionieren also da sind tatsächlich
zwei spannende welten auf der einen
seite ist es so eine subskription modell
was wächst nach der anderen seite ist
die färbe entwicklung aber auch richtig
gut das heißt nur um das technisch zu
verstehen es wird sondern technischer
marker in der audiospur von dem podcast
gesetzt und irgendwann adserver spielt
dann die werbung aus die in einem regal
zur verfügung steht die zu diesem
podcast passt was ähnlich wäre zudem wie
es in einer web seite funktioniert der
markt würde daher entsprechend reifer
werden
genau das ist sondern eine klassische
entwicklung würde ich fast schon sagen
und die podcast die ist ja mittlerweile
auch schon ewig gibt so langsam dahin
kommen und das wird spannend zu sehen
wie sich das entwickelt
ich bin da auch mal ich bin davon
überzeugt dass das weiter wachsen wird
und das ist aber auch vielleicht noch
ein bisschen professioneller wird weil
auch in den
auf der vermarkter seite wird einfach
das verständnis für podcast wachsen und
auch die das erfolgs also dieses
erfolgserlebnis podcast wird dort habe
ich für werbekunden immer besser werden
weil es auch messbarer wird und ein
bisschen transparenter und deswegen ist
es glaube ich für den kunden ganz gut
weil er die werbung wird nicht glaube
ich so werden wie im radio ist sondern
die wird weiterhin so ein bisschen
schöner netter und nicht so auf
abverkauf drängend seien mit dem pott
und so ein bisschen mehr personelle die
haben weil ich glaube diese abtrennung
zum radio und ist gar nicht böse gemeint
das wird er glaube ich schon noch
vorherrschen
jetzt haben wir relativ global über
diesen markt gesprochen lass uns doch
mal etwas näher rhein suchen und zwar in
die altersstruktur der hörer ganz am
anfang hat es so gesagt also hörerzahl
ab 14 steigt das heißt wahrscheinlich
vor 14 wird es gar nicht gemessen und so
aber könnte man denn sagen gibt es wenn
man in dieser kohorte von 14 bis weiß
ich nicht 85 jahren der hörer rein
belegt sind diese hörer tendenziell
älter oder ist es eher ein jüngeres
podcast publikum wenn jünger wie sehr
dominieren die diesen marken sind die
älteren vollkommen außen vor
fangen wir damit mal andere dann reden
wir danach noch mal über das
bildungsniveau und über dass das
einkommen der leute aber erstmal
wirklich jetzt rein die altersstruktur
ist podcast und jetzt eine thesen frage
zu stellen
vor allem das für junge leute ist es
tatsächlich
ich glaube so zwischen 30 und 49
jährigen
da ist es die sitzen die meisten
podcasthörer und das ist auch was wo
podcast glaube ich mitgewachsen sind
weil man das doch so ein bisschen
entdeckt hat und es schießen aber die
jungen sehr stark nach während bei den
älteren
da hält sich dann doch also nicht in
grenzen aber da ist es doch so dass der
markt der wächst noch nicht so stark
das ist aber auch wieder spannend zu
sehen was ist denn für ist ob sie ältere
hörer teilweise radio on demand was ja
auch im podcast ist es überhaupt als
podcast identifizieren also ich glaube
das ist in dieser radio sozialisierten
schicht laufen die podcast sehr gut und
in der jüngeren zielgruppe wird
das über nie die das was partie frei
gerade macht und was auch apple podcast
macht einfach irre podcast so ein
bisschen dass das medium der stunde auch
sind dass darüber hat sich die
aufmerksamkeit darauf kommt und dann
hört man sich das auch stärker an aber
es ist glaube ich auch
woher viel kommt ist ihm aus dem bereich
youtube dass da sehr viele an eine als
beiwerk im podcast machen
das sind also die wichtigste podcast
plattform überhaupt ne sie habe das ist
doch gar nicht erwähnt aber ja genau
youtube werden die meisten podcast
gehört das finde ich auch immer wieder
krass und das ist auch so was wie man
glaube ich gar nicht daran denkt wenn
man sich selbst so gelernt hat darüber
podcast zu hören und es ist auch
mittlerweile sind kleiner raubkopierer
markt weil spotify exklusives podcast
findet man auch immer wieder ganz gern
auf youtube und kann danach hören also
darf gibt es immer wieder so ein kleines
der ein kleines lokal wo man sich die
podcast noch anhören kann aber es ist
schon ein junges medium und aber auch
ein sehr diverses medium ist so ja noch
immer ganz positiven entwicklung wo man
eigentlich alle altersgruppen erreichen
kann
und weil man sagen muss spotify an sich
ist schon sehr sehr jung
das sieht man auch ganz stark an der
alters unterteilung die spotify anbietet
wo es glaube ich bis 35 sind immer so
zwei bis drei jahres schritte und ab 50
sind es dann zehn bis 15 jahre schritte
wo man sich die grafiken rausgegeben
lassen kann und ich glaube dass ich dann
auch 60 bis 150 was angegeben wird als
eine halters kohorte da sieht man mal
ganz klar wo der markt oder wo spotify
den fokus drauf setzt pro jahr 650
natürlich auch schon ein guter witz das
würde dann auch sehr sehr stark aber ich
glaube so was viele wie wie mediatheken
oder so die auch von radiosendern kommen
wo einfach radio sendungen on demand
angeboten werden ohne musik das wird
auch in der älteren zielgruppe benutzen
aber auch in der jüngeren zielgruppe
kunst ganz stark ich habe ja gerade
vielleicht hört man dass so ein bisschen
mein schreibtisch ist voller zettel und
ich raschel hier so ein bisschen rum ich
habe gerade was gefunden
auch eine studie wo die podcast nutzung
auf die einzelnen plattformen aufgeteilt
ist es bestätigt sich also und
plattformen der podcast nutzung in
deutschland 61 prozent youtube 53
spotify und beides grad erwähnt ist die
ard audi o thek also da wo die einzelnen
rundfunkanstalten ihre sachen
hinterlegen sind ist auf platz 3 30
prozent noch vor ort den ball mit 24 und
apple podcast mit 21 also eine wirklich
interessante marktaufteilung ja und in
der tat die er so häufig würde ich auch
bei der politik dann eher etwas ältere
bürgerinnen und hörer vermuten
das ist ja naheliegend und
zusammensetzung von denen du vom
audiomarkt kann man auch sagen dass
diese technik affinen gebildet und
loyales was irgendwo alles sinn macht
zum thema podcast und gebildet heißt
auch gut verdient überdurchschnittlich
wahrscheinlich genau das ist schon kann
man sich auf jeden fall davon davon
ableiten
ich habe allerdings einfach keine studie
gesehen wo drinsteht dass man nicht die
gebildeten leute hat deswegen kann man
das immer so ein bisschen ich und das
richtet sich dann ja auch immer schon
wieder an potentielle werbekunden die
damit eingefangen werden genau das muss
man gar nicht ein bisschen mitdenken
weist aber ich glaube schon dass das auf
viele zutrifft beim podcast an sich sind
ja auch immer diesen universum wo man zu
jedem thema wenn ich einen ganzen
podcast zumindest eine episode findet
und da kann man daraus für die
persönliche fortbildung ein bisschen
darüber machen weilstetten wikipedia
artikel zu lesen kann man sich auch mal
eine episode anhören wo man das ganze
dann noch so ein bisschen lebhafter
erklärt also ich komme eigentlich ein
studium generale was da angeboten wird
ich habe mir du hast ja auch zahlen von
bitkom research bericht schon eben
gerade angesprochen gibt es ja auch
welche
es ist unglaublich wie breit verteilt
die themen in der auswertung der
beliebtesten podcast themen ist also mit
45% des nachrichten und politik waren
beliebtesten aber ganz ganz nah dran
also überhaupt kein großer unterschied
und den film und fernsehen comedy sport
und freizeit und so und dann gibt es
eine zweite kategorie
da sind aber auch schon fast alle wieder
gleichauf mit wissenschaft und bildung
und technologie wo wir hier im digipak
podcast auch zu hause sind und
gesundheit das ist fast alles offen der
selben niveau oder so es ist
unwahrscheinlich bereit aber in dieser
breite werden die themen von den
hörerinnen und hörern tatsächlich auch
alle abgeholt und ein bereich den man da
gar nicht so sieht es auch dieses was
auch noch aus wirtschaftlicher sicht
glaube ich ganz spannend ist das thema
wie man den internen podcasts nutzen
kann das also firmenintern zur
mitarbeiterkommunikation genau das
hatten wir jetzt für für die ziele vom
quartal wurden die in einem kleinen
podcast aufgenommen die man sich dann
jederzeit anhören kann
und ich glaube da ist auch für eine für
die öffentlichkeitsarbeit oder pr ist es
durchaus ein spannendes thema wie man
selbst mit dem podcast themen besetzen
kann und so ein bisschen öffentlichkeit
schaffen kann oder auch intern im
unternehmen die allermeisten mitarbeiter
fühlen sich in der regel immer zu
schlecht informiert oft ist auch was
dran und da könnte man tatsächlich dem
begegnen
you can never over communicator mir ein
früherer von adobe mal gesagt hat und
das war auf die interne kommunikation
bezogen lass uns noch mal ein ganz
kleines bisschen über unsere erfahrungen
im eigenen haus leben weil das ganze
wird dann vielleicht auch noch etwas
konkreter um zu erkennen und das ist ja
auch für diejenigen die sich für den
markt insgesamt interessieren spannend
zu wissen wo man da eigentlich am
schnellsten vorankommen kann wir haben
ja ungefähr ein dutzend podcasts im haus
müssen wir jetzt niemanden mit quellen
dass alles aufzuzählen
aber es gibt also die sind alle auf
ihrem niveau erfreulich unterwegs aber
es gibt einen derart wirklich heraus und
man ahnt dass wahrscheinlich schon weil
ich eben gerade gesagt hat podcast thema
nachrichten und politik ist auch im
gesamtmarkt am interessantesten
das ist der podcast für deutschland sagt
auch mal ein bisschen was dazu wie sich
der so in den vergangenen anderthalb
jahren in vier jahren entwickelt hat
er hat sich sehr sehr gut entwickelt
also das war
wir sind jetzt auf einem niveau wo wir
vorher nicht gedacht hätten dass wir
dahin kommen also das waren doch
steigerungsraten wo wir dreifache
vierfache teilweise rausgeholt haben aus
einem monat was wir vorher hatten weil
man einfach da auch und das mussten wir
glaube ich auch lernen
die themenauswahl ist viel wichtiger und
auch dass man aus dem podcast 1
ein gesamtprodukt macht und trotzdem
täglich die themen besetzen kann und ich
finde es immer noch krass wie sich der
podcast während der pandemie entwickelt
hat wo wir am anfang hatten wir
teilweise mehrere einem podcast mehrere
themen und dann wurde das doch zu einem
wir nehmen uns ein thema von bearbeiten
das aus verschiedenen blickwinkeln und
ich war er bei der entwicklung mit dabei
und das war schon spannend mal so ein
daily wie man es im internet sagen weil
dann täglich erscheint zu entwickeln
anstatt zu den anderen wöchentlichen
formaten weil das aus redaktions sich
natürlich ein ganz anderes brettes aber
auch aus konzeption und vermarktung und
da haben wir die audio redaktion mit dem
podcast für deutschland schon sehr sehr
gutes stück hingestellt was man auch
immer wieder sieht dass wir auf drittel
der podcast mit mehr zitiert man kriegt
die die großen gäste die dann natürlich
auch wieder auf den plattformen ziehen
und es ist auch journalist es einfach
ein spannendes produkt was auch wieder
eine andere herangehensweise glaube ich
an die redaktion bringt als zu schreiben
oder ein video zu machen
lerner klar ist dass wir müssen völlig
was neues dazu lernen gilt ja auch für
mich
wir sind in den beruf also jedenfalls
alle die die etwas länger schon dabei
sind man könnte also alex würde auch
sagen die so alt sind
die sind ja über das reine schreiben in
diesem beruf reingekommen und müssen
jetzt alles mögliche mitdenken und
daneben auch die moderation von
solche sachen ja stimmt wir haben das ja
alles entwickelt haben am anfang so
ausgelegt dass man über zwei drei themen
ins bild gesetzt worden ist und haben
dann relativ schnell erkannten jahn ist
es viel besser auf ein einziges thema zu
fokussieren und das aus
unterschiedlichen blickwinkeln an dem
tag aktuell zu beleuchten
das kommt in der tat sehr gut an also
ein podcast klar die jede
journalistische produkt muss natürlich
auch sich dann also man muss schon
bereit sein das auch immer wieder weiter
zu entwickeln
bei digitec geht es auch wir hatten für
viel weniger externe gäste und das ist
jetzt beinahe die regel geworden
das finde ich auch schön bei podcasts
das ist natürlich aus redaktioneller
sicht sehr aufwendig aber wenn man jetzt
sich willig über ändern was an unserer
app oder wir ändern was an der webseite
ist da viel mehr was man noch an beiwerk
machen muss und da das ist dann in
anführungszeichen
man schneidet das anders zusammen und
spricht das anders ein oder produziert
einfach anders also da die redaktion
finde ich immer noch den den maximalen
einfluss darauf was bei rauskommt
verändert wenn der website sind dann
doch mehrere gewerke die zusammenspielen
bis man mal was ändern kann was jetzt
nicht ein text format ist sondern da ist
das ganze produkt sehr schnell angepasst
und deswegen auch flexibel da stimmt man
kann von einem tag auf den anderen wenn
man in der lage ist das umzusetzen
als moderator oder so dass natürlich
konzeptionell ändern das ist extrem
reizvoll da hat es in der vergangenen
woche apropos interne mitarbeiter
kommunikation so eine präsentation wo du
auch über unsere audio aktivitäten
gesprochen hast da hat es dann eine zahl
an der wand verraten wir jetzt auch
einfach mal extern wie viele downloads
und streams pro monat hat allein jetzt
die faz in ihrem podcast produkten in
diesen knappen dutzend dass ich da
erwähnt habe auch was für eine zahl
kommen wir da
da kommen wir jetzt seit vier monaten
regelmäßig immer so auf über 1 mio
und das ist schon richtig cool also den
wert ist wo man am anfang dachte bis wir
damals sind und dann ist dann ich sehe
sehr erfreulich und schnell oder nicht
schnell gegangen aber das ist eine
schöne entwicklung die man da sieht und
immer doch noch so eins und werte an dem
man sich festhalten kann wenn man die
million geknackt also genau wie schnell
sie einem digitalen geschäft immer
relativ aber wenn man weiß dass da im
februar 18 so lange ist es ja auch noch
nicht ja im prinzip eine null stand
dann ist es also von von null auf über
eine millionen schon wirklich einen sehr
sehr interessanter neuer markt so audio
ist aber mehr als das was wir hier jetzt
im moment machen und alle podcaster
dieser welt in diesem moment tun es gibt
mit der hilfe von immer besseren
algorithmen längst auch und da ist
längst das falsche wort weil so richtig
gut funktioniert es erst seit kürzerer
zeit auch die möglichkeit sich texte
vorlesen zu lassen ohne dass ein mensch
damit befasst ist es nennt sich text to
speech und führt dazu dass man jedes
journalistische produkt das bis jetzt
nur verschriftlicht vorgelegen hat
plötzlich auch hören kann und auch das
ist eine spannende entwicklung
vielleicht fiel es auch noch nach kurz
was jetzt in diesem fall unser haus aber
das steht auch nur das porto für einen
gesamt trend im markt was wir dort im
moment unternehmen genau wir bieten in
unserer hat netapp und in unserer kiosk
app bzw
digitale zeitung habe bieten wir an dass
jeder text der dort verfügbar ist auch
im so genannten text to speech verfahren
vorgelesen wird
dazu schicken wir die artikel zu einem
in dem fall ist es eine sprachsynthese
sein sprach roboter von google und dort
werden die die inhalte vertont und das
funktioniert so ein bisschen so dass man
bei google hat einen ganzen haufen audio
formate und audio also wörter die
vorgelesen sind und dass wir dann wieso
einem durchgegangen und gekuppelt passt
dieser satz gerade dahin und dann
versucht die maschine zu verstehen und
auch mit algorithmen und machine
learning festzulegen ja wie der satz den
klingen könnte und das ist für den
anfang sehr sehr gut man merkt natürlich
immer schnell dass es eine maschine ist
das ist aber finde ich gar nicht so
schlimm weil das eigentlich schöne ist
dass wir dadurch schaffen wir haben
jeden artikel auch als audio verfügbar
und das schafft auch so eine ganz andere
art der nutzung weil das ist jetzt
möglich sich die faz im auto vorlesen zu
lassen oder auf dem weg zur arbeit
und wenn man ein bisschen natürlich sind
jetzt so gut sein wie eine menschliche
stimme aber es ist schon sehr nah und
man kommt da glaube ich ganz ganz gut
mit weg und wir haben das leben in der
pfalz netapp und der kiosk app
eingebunden wo man sich eine ausgabe
vorlesen lassen kann oder einfach die
aktuellsten nachrichten aus jedem
ressort und das ist sehr sehr spannendes
projekt wurde auch immer noch weiter
forschen und entwickeln weil man immer
wieder merkt gerade mit neuen politikern
hat es dann doch manchmal die sprache
stimme noch ein problem das den namen
betrifft
da muss man auch ein bisschen
experimentierfreudig sein und probieren
und ich habe zuletzt einen tests gesehen
wo ich schon dachte daran hält man auch
denken können
künstliches atmen wenn man das drunter
liegt also das wirklich jemand luft holt
oder zumindest simuliert dass man luft
hole dann wirkt das alles noch mal einen
ganzen takt natürlicher und das sind so
kleine hexe die man glaube ich immer
weiter ausprobieren kann und da auch
wieder vielleicht am format spielen dass
man sagt okay der kommentar kommt jetzt
aus der politik das heißt die stimme
sollte ihr ernsthaft sein die das
vorlesen oder der kommentar kommt aus
einem anderen ressort ist ja vielleicht
auch eine kolumne die klasse dann kann
er vielleicht ein bisschen lockerer
vorgetragen werden solche sachen sind
glaube ich ganz spannenden da einfach
einen der neue formate zu schaffen die
das ein klassischer anwendungsfall von
der künstlichen intelligenz was wir ja
hier im podcast auch häufiger besprechen
die dann immer weiter lernt je mehr
daten da vorgelesen worden sind um so
schlau wird das ding in summe sich
stetig verbessernden prozess gerne schon
genau die dahinter steckt genau und
manchmal macht einen sprung zurück das
merkt man dann auch wenn irgendwas was
funktioniert hat nicht funktioniert
da ist es dann aber das sind auch
kleinigkeiten und ansonsten sieht man da
immer wieder große sprünge und ich
glaube da ist auch die microsoft bietet
es an google bietet an und natürlich
auch amazon und die befruchten sich da
glaube ich ganz gut es kommen aber auch
immer wieder kleine plattformen dazu die
auch wieder neues war ideen einbringen
wie das mit dem hartmann kommt zb aus
einer kleineren firma und das finde ich
dann immer ganz spannend wie man die
entwicklung sieht und wie es dann doch
wieder so ein sprung macht manchmal in
der entwicklung
das musste ja das naheliegende kommt
dann doch oft erst in den kleineren
teams wird dann neben dem atmen das ist
in der tat eine pfiffige idee also zwei
aspekte noch das dass man so eine
zeitung also ganz klassisch seine e
paper ausgabe sich auch vorlesen lassen
kann es natürlich oft ältere leute die
möglicherweise schwierigkeiten haben das
alles noch zu lesen also durch das
augenlicht ja ein großer fortschritt
richtung barrierefreiheit davon jetzt
auch nicht vergessen das freut mich
gerade für für die gruppe unserer
leserinnen und leser total und dann auf
der anderen seite jüngere menschen die
jetzt mit einem wort wie apple k play
noch was anfangen können auch für die
ist es halt interessant auch ganz neu
diese über diese faz
das netapp kann man jetzt auch einfach
auch also die erscheint jetzt nativ auch
im apple play und man kann sich eben
über k play und diese app das was du
gesagt hast auch vorspielen lassen mit
dieser empfehlung und einem pipapo wo
dann halt eine ganz persönliche playlist
wiederum auf basis künstlicher
intelligenz meines lese und höre
verhaltens entsteht und sich wenn man so
will jeder seinen eigenen nachrichten
podcast zusammenstellt eben auf der
basis seiner eigenen interessen und es
spannend das ist super und ich finde
auch als als android menschen natürlich
auch für android auto
das ist natürlich auch ich hoffe der
platte ja nicht ganz so groß da muss ich
aber darauf bestehen dass sie ganz ganz
spannende sache dieses offenen fremdes
display dann einfach die fasnet mal in
einer ganz anderen art laufen zu lassen
wo man wirklich nur sich audio hören
kann und es bringt uns auch vor viele
neue möglichkeiten wenn man könnte jetzt
auch mal überlegen
aktuell haben wir noch playlisten also
text to speech und podcast sind so ein
bisschen getrennt
aber das zu kombinieren dass man mit so
einer radioshow hat in anführungszeichen
wo man mit dem podcast für deutschland
anfängt und dann die themen kriegt die
behandelt werden aber aus einer maschine
vorgelesen und oder auch aus den
persönlichen aus dem persönlichen
vorschlägen zusammengebaut das sind
alles so projekt im konzept immer wieder
auch weiterhin daran denken und daran
arbeiten ja das ist wie soll ich sagen
also dieser podcast mag hat hat auch
ewig in kinderschuhen gesteckt und dann
plötzlich abgehoben bei diesen text to
speech ist es glaube ich auch ein wenig
so wie wir müssen den hörern jetzt auch
nichts vormachen wir reden da jetzt noch
nicht über einen massenmarkt an zuspruch
das geht gerade erst so richtig los und
trotzdem hat man so eine ahnung was an
möglichkeiten da vor einem liegt und man
hat die chance dabei zu sein wenn etwas
neues entsteht und das gilt für tts und
und diese verbindung von künstlicher
intelligenz beim vorlesen mit der
beobachtungen des eisen eigenen lese und
hörverstehen schlüssen die daraus dann
wieder gezogen werden halt eben gerade
erst und ja also ganz spannende neue
möglichkeiten wirklich interessant also
wäre es einfach mal ausprobieren möchte
ob es bei android ist ob bei uns ist und
oder auch mit einem wettbewerbsprodukt
hat es gibt völlig egal einfach damit
mal rum zu spielen ist schon spannend
und ja du du bist mit dem was du bei uns
machst damit drin und ja es gibt
wahrscheinlich eine interessante jobs
lieber florian dass wir so in den
vergangenen jahren gemacht hast also das
ist schon stark auch da geht ja dass ein
großteil dieser arbeit hätte es ja vor
zwei drei jahren noch gar nicht gegeben
und jetzt sieht man halt den zuspruch
ist kommen da die werbeeinnahmen beine
sind die hörerzahlen da ist und schon
toll dass ich habe den ersten podcast
hatten wir als wird einspruch als
beiboot für ein anderes produkt und das
war schon schön dass du zu entwickeln in
alle ein bisschen ruhe und dann war auch
wieder schön den podcast für deutschland
der einfach so als flaggschiff geplant
war aufzusetzen wo man dann auch ganz
anders arbeiten konnte noch viel
direkter mit mit euch mit der redaktion
was schönes projekt war und auch ein
erfolgreiches projektes deswegen mit
audio es echt viel passiert in den
letzten jahren das ist schon so drüber
spricht wird es auch erstmal richtig
bewusst das ist musik drin haben den
kader kann ich mir jetzt nicht
verkneifen liebe hörerinnen und hörer
vielen dank fürs zuhören für ihre zeit
für den die tech podcast seitdem es den
digitec podcast gibt oder auch am
heutigen tag an dem sie uns zugehört
haben wenn sie laufend informiert werden
möchten über alles was in der welt der
technik und der mobilität so spannendes
neues am start ist empfehle ich ihnen
die faz digitec app die es und diesmal
sag ich es mit blick auf unseren gast in
der reihenfolge für android geräte und
für
ios geräte in den entsprechenden stores
zum download gibt
der podcast ist ein fester bestandteil
davon also schauen sie gerne mal in
diesem podcast wie gesagt es da auch
fest eingebunden natürlich themen halten
wir sie rund um die uhr auf dem
laufenden
nächste woche der digi tec podcast
wieder dann mit mit mir als moderator
alex ist weiter im urlaub danach machen
einen kleinen wechsel der macht er das
zwei wochen und dann sind irgendwann die
sommerferien auch schon wieder zu ende
falls sie in denselben sind schöne
solche und bis ganz bald tschüss danke
florian gerner tschüss
[Musik]